how's it going everybody Aaron Sampson
here to show you how to find Sam Fisher
and goes for your own wild lands and
then show you the cutscenes first head
on over to the la Cruz region where Sam
will give you his location sneak into a
base without killing anybody and help
Sam hack the base while doing the exact
opposite of what I just said pretty much
killing everybody also make sure that
you pack a grenade launcher to drop a
couple of helicopters on the way out and
then head back to a safe house for the
final cutscene all right here it is
enjoy the original Billy badass himself
Sam Fisher is in the crease he needs
your help with something
extracurricular follow his lead and I'd
advise you to stay on his good side
that's what I read you five-by-five I'm
in country without my usual a girl you
tell us what you need we'll make it
happen I'm gonna want somebody to watch
my back I'll drop you a line Roger that
look this is not the time to be playing
cowboy translating don't drop any bodies
unless I give you the word copy
understood this is a stealth op looks
like we're riding shotgun with Sam
Fisher buddy of mine who went to paladin
nine security worked with Fischer on a
knr in South America reliable as hell
but not a guy you invited for dinner
with the family I guess he's had it
rough for the most lost both his parents
music
apparently somebody faked his daughter's
death
he's been shot stabbed tortured bastard
still tickin like Rasputin or something
that takes something powerful to keep at
it after all that [ __ ] happens to you
Fischer has spent decades walking side
by side with death
that's tough sometimes I think about the
bad things we do for the good of our
country we travel overseas take some
lives ruin others I'd do it all again in
a heartbeat but I still don't know if
I'd go as far as Sam Fisher does I got
eyes and matchwood so you're what a
ghost looks like huh who's our friend
this is the CIA gone rogue stole a whole
lot of serious Intel out of Langley
scuttlebutt is trying to sell it to
sound a buzzer if he's selling to them
and what's he doing in a unit at camp
I'm thinking he's trying to buy
protection huh they work out too well
for him did it you got exactly what he
deserved
let's have a look what we got here
son of a [ __ ] what put the Langley
Intel on a unit that server now I can
hack this but the problem is as soon as
I open that door we're gonna have a
whole lot of undesirables come looking
for dangos what do you need from me I
need you up top all on security look
problem is is this gonna take some time
yeah I got a hack the server download
the Langley files and then bleach the
hard drive okay unit that shows up you
turn on the faucet hooah
enemy incoming right just keep me busy
this will take a minute what the
hornet's nest
Linda how are you doing
you're looking good real good
it's Karen today you look like you've
clocked some miles since we last spoke
yeah a few I've heard they don't make
them like me anymore there was this
other guy though army infiltration he
wore a bandana or something
I heard he finally retired really yep
swollen yeah Sam yeah you got it
I do I'll be delivering it personally
Grimm sent word about what chairman of
the Joint Chiefs says there's a possible
empty quiver I can get you airborne in
one hour really you know a guy once said
the price of success is hard work and
dedication it sounds like he knew a
thing or two yeah it's good working with
you sir and the sir just call me Sam
look you're real good at what you do you
watch your six huh
an hour huh that's right you got any
coffee
this is Bolivia of course there's coffee